ah
the last day of summer may happen in
September but games with gold will keep
going all month long games with gold has
four new titles for September that are
all playable and acquirable on xbox one
and free to those with an active xbox
live gold subscription starting on sep
tember first and launching into games
with gold is the brand new indie RPG
earth lock festival of magic in this
beautiful ombre landscape clay is Amon
and join unlikely heroes to save your
uncle from an ancient cult next up on
sep tember 16th get a new perspective on
a beloved series with assassin's creed
chronicles china help Xiao John avenge
her fallen Brotherhood in a 2.5 d twist
on the classic Assassin's Creed series
using stealth tools and hiding spots to
find and eliminate her targets on the
xbox 360 and Xbox one via backward
compatibility jump behind the wheel in
the dynamic open-world street racer
Forza horizon with over 300 cars to
unlock and an open world full of
challenges the Forza horizon festival is
a celebration that will keep you coming
back again and again also on sep tember
16th be fast get airborne and always
land on your feet in mirrors edge make
your way across an oppressive city to
deliver key messages and fight a deadly
regime in this free running action
classic to redeem the titles simply
click on the gold area on your xbox one
on your xbox 360 or even on the web at
xbox calm forward slash games with gold
your new games will automatically appear
in the ready to install section of your
xbox one with Xbox Live Gold you are
part of the world's premier gaming
community